hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu einem video was ich schon
sehr auf bei anderen youtube angesehen
habe was ich allerdings nie gedacht
hatte dass es bei mir wirklich klappt
ich habe diese website hier gesehen
internet archiv wayback machine und man
kann da irgendein link einfügen und dann
zeigt die website einem an die oft über
zeitung schon bei gespeichert wurden
beim einem kanal ist beispielsweise
schon so dass main kanal das erste mal
am 16 februar gespeichert wurde 2012 das
heißt wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise man
hierbei 2015 bin und einfach mal auf 22
august clique dann öffnet er meine
website am 22 august dieses jahres am 22
august dieses jahres seien main kanal
genauso aus und zwar das letzte video
hochgeladen hatte war entschuldigungen
vor einer stunde und davor meine
freundin also das mit max am 22 august
war ich noch im urlaub und ich hatte
diese ganzen leute hier in meinen
feature channels ich hatte hier noch
meine alten shirts und hoodies also den
alten schock und den banner und das
programm jetzt auch schon ein halbes
jahr oder so also das ist eigentlich
alles erst mal gleich geblieben und war
u 3 war gerade noch aktiv das weiß ich
weil ich die playlist ganz oben da das
tier allerdings alles überhaupt nicht
interessant ist gehen merkmals jahr 2012
und gehen beispielsweise kommen wir
gehen auf den 21 februar
da hatte ich nämlich geburtstag wels
ecken slater
altmann design von vor drei jahren
wien es ist das sendet mir fällt grad
auf das am 21
februar 2012 16 jahre alt wurde das
heißt da durfte ich das erste mal
irgendwas mehr in meinem leben also
freunde main kanal die seinen vor drei
jahren war das war mein kanal design vor
drei jahren ich wusste noch dass diese
als er mir kommen die tränen das ist
voll schön das war doch diese zeit wo
man das youtube kanal die dann wirklich
so komplett anpassen konnte kommen
konnte hier unten so trieben packen man
konnte hier in den text einigen sachen
so geld machen wo man mir folgen konnte
und da kommt man dann so drauf klicken
oder so man konnte sogar hier oben wo
eigentlich so der normalen texterin
stand kommt noch was reinschreiben ins
design habe ich beispielsweise
reingeschrieben livestream doppelpunkt
offline und dann hab ich hier so ein
links drinnen wo man beispielsweise zu
meinem facebook und zu was ist denn das
wo führt das hin 8
das führt sogar noch zu dem channel konz
blog wo ich blogs und comedys gemacht
habe junge alter wie geil ist das denn
ach ja stimmt da gab es sogar noch diese
preise so platz 74 mostert scribe dalton
comedians in germany das ist worauf was
soll ich da viele preise alter ich
glaube nämlich da gab es auch noch gar
keine gamer kategorie weil ich steht
alles nur mit comedians nicht nur
eigentlich gar nicht lustig hier in den
kommentaren halt wirklich soweit mein
geburtstag war alles gute hat die
birthday alles cool teddy bear city
university university über konvertierte
jüdin standboxen sandboxing sondern auch
e-mails interessante schau mal da ich
zwölf 1858 schreibers und ich hab
geträumt am ersten august 2011 das heißt
das ganze ist zirka ein halbes jahr her
ich hatte in einem halben jahr 12.000
zum treiber all das hätte ich nie
gedacht ich dachte ich hätte für die
ersten 2003 ein jahr gebraucht gras
hatte den 2406 kreuz mit hatte 45.000
subscribers sparkarte 14.000 alter das
kann übels krank für meinen kopf einfach
dann nehme ich mal genau das nächste
jahr 2013 da können wir jetzt nicht zum
februar anklicken aber wir können mal
eben beispielsweise kommen wir gehen mal
in den august gehen am 5 august 2013
da sind jetzt main kanal mein gott
da war schon wieder ein anderes youtube
design drin und so seinen kanal dann aus
hatte ich mich in den kanal noch drin
vielleicht soviel minecraft gemacht
hatte 1.6 motsi zum pvp was da alles
gibt pvp mit mir läuft man nie so gut
also ihr könnt euch ein video pvp tricks
mit luca hier oben ansehen
da könnt ihr vielleicht ein bisschen was
lernen oder auch nicht ach da gingen die
mannschaft wächst gerade alles so
richtig los das war sie die erste serie
die bei mir richtig gut angekommen ist
da war auch noch das megaprojekt in
vollem gange da die erste voll mit denen
aufgenommen danach mit cap und kummer
ich habe dein bruder geschrieben mit cam
und jetzt schauen wir uns mal einen
kanal mal 2014 im 4 mai 2014 an am
vierten mai 2014 wirklich schon dieses
design hier tatsächlich drin wo ich
ja tatsächlich nicht so erfreulich
geschaut das gefiel mir aber auch ganz
gut ball hat sich dieses etwas gechipt
mäßige drin das quasi in die sammlerin
dieser kleine bogen drin war
ja
gefällt mir tatsächlich ganz gut
eigentlich was mir gerade auffällt ist
zwar alles beim alten ich hatte da
instagram wir vorne ich hatte hier den
kanal so banal alles mögliche der name
allerdings die kanäle von den anderen
youtube sind die aktuellen das hätten
sie vielleicht tatsächlich mal besser
machen können auch hier unten wieder die
facts gefeatured minecraft bahro und
auch hier da hatte ich diese ersten da
hatte ich mein kampf mit mister morgen
alter ich ich könnte ich ratlos
das sind richtig schöne alte erinnerungs
momente wir können jetzt allerdings auch
meine anderen link eingeben oder gebe
ich einfach mal ein twitter.com /
kontrakt dann schauen wir uns mal wieder
mal die seien die letzten jahre aus ok
irgendwie gibt sogar ein problem und
zwar wenn ich am 21 februar
beispielsweise draufklicken komme ich
auf diese seite hier
und wenn ich am 16 februar drauf clique
komme ich auch auf diese seite hier
irgendwie funktioniert das hier gar
nicht so richtig mal schauen ob mit
facebook.com / von crafter tv geht
mein gott da ist meine facebook-seite
alles baut sich gerade nacheinander auf
und hatte ich sogar noch den spruch
hallo meiner
das aktualität sich ja die ganze zeit
irgendwie selbst vor drei jahren habe
ich so gemacht dass ich bei facebook
einfach irgendwas geschrieben habe dann
hier ansehen und dann den linken bild
dazu und das mache ich einfach immer
noch bei facebook habe ich überhaupt
keine entwicklung ja irgendwie
aktualisiert sich diese facebook-seite
nach und nach ich habe hier meine hände
oben und der aktualisierte irgendwie die
ganze zeit irgendwie kriegt er das nicht
hin aber ich denke so den haupt kern des
videos komme ich euch rüber bringen und
zwar einfach meinen kanal von vor drei
jahren anschauen ich finde das immer
mega interessant und ich kann einmal
voll emotions voll werden weil das ist
halt einfach irgendwie ein stück von
meiner vergangenheit die wir uns gerade
angeschaut habe mir egal da heute aber
der dreizehnte dezember ist machen wir
auch wieder das dreizehnte türchen im
adventskalender auf wo ihr ein geschenk
diesmal drin haben meine lieben freunde
also quasi so ein ganz normales geschenk
und in diesem geschenk drin ist
irgendwie so eine mütze sonne kochmütze
oder so ich tu dir einfach mal rein
macht das geschenk zu und stellt sie in
unsere kleine winterlandschaft zu
erinnern und den anderen hier und damit
würde ich auch sagen meine lieben
freunde während sich diese website hier
die ganze zeit noch aktualisiert sage
ich einfach mal wenn es euch gefallen
hat das video soll ich das noch mal
machen mit anderen webseiten schreibt
webseiten dazu die kommentare